hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar validating antibodies for
research applications in IHC presented
by dr. will how it and Demian clock
field I'm Christie Joel of lab rats and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by laberd's and brought to you
by leica Biosystems to learn more about
our sponsor please visit leica
Biosystems calm now before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
best offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located to the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I now present today's speaker dr. will
Howitt director of antibody validation
and characterization ab cam also
speaking with dr. how it is Damien
cocktailed global product manager
bond-like a bio systems for complete
biographies on our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
after how it you may now begin our
presentation
Thank You Christy for that introduction
and welcome to a webinar on validating
antibodies for rhesus applications and I
you see I'm will Howard and I would
firstly like to thank for the
opportunity to present on this topic and
I'm hoping that by the end of it I will
giving you an idea of the frame workers
needed to face successfully validated
antibodies into your lab so the talk
plan are going to go around a general
structure so the first thing to answer
is really what is the problem
so we wear why does IC so difficult for
finding antibodies
well then go into some details and
around some of the bombs that can can
come up during a man I see staining plan
and then we can go into how we can
resolve those and using your particular
methods such as I like AB on the door to
make that better
and hopefully that will give you the
framework or the foundations in this
case and to be able to build on those
Underwood's you've used into into other
applications so I would like to start
trusted with the paper you can see in
the bottom right hand corner and I've
taken this quote from this paper and I
particularly like it and it's because I
read out you it's it's sharp and
beautiful pictures and obtained
investigators often tend to believe that
the antibodies are specific the main
concern is are the cost involved in
disproving spurious results of other
laboratories huge and often much higher
the course of proper testing in the
first place and what I really want to
take away from that is that antibody
validation is can be time-consuming and
it can be difficult but if you put the
right framework in place and you can be
confident over the results of that
framework then you can be confident the
results you wanted with your specific M
and that data you can take forward into
other applications it's getting all that
framework right in your lab and in your
hands is the important part and doing it
correctly so why don't antibodies work
for formalin-fixed issue well there are
many reasons but at least one of them if
you take up
team booting is obviously not just a
long string of amino acids it's folded
up and there are many proteins alongside
and if you were to look at two
particular epitopes cases a blue epitope
and a red ever talk after formula
fixation you get disulfide bonds being
formed and those do two things one they
help to create a structure and they bind
the proteins together and that is
helpful for us in pathology because it
means that the tissue in itself is
harder and that means it will be time
come out with a microtome blade then and
we can do so much this part and embed it
so it is helpful but it's also hinders
as are many ways as well so if you take
two antibodies the blue antibody will
find us as epitope and because it's
right next to it and where the red
epital is blocked and it's blocked
because the the formalin bonds are
blocking the access of antibody to this
epitope so then you ant attitude
retrieval and by adding energy retrieval
you break down some Wiggles bonds you
break down some parts of the protein
it's alpha allow the blue and the good
in this case to bind and the red add the
way to find this target so you've got to
remember that that's not what the
problem lies and although you can use
various methods to try and resolve that
you've got to be remember that you've
got to get this specificity you're going
to know your target really well and bear
in mind that there are a number of
things I can go wrong so the first one I
want to demonstrate to you and by all
means if this is daughter ah exclusive
list if the antidote evil can change the
Backman standing so on the left hand
panel you have a marker this is a marker
for phosphorus k1
it's using in this case a epital
retrieval probably er one and but this
marker is a as a protein kinase but it's
used as phosphorylation of a
transcription factor to the expected be
nuclear staining and it is perfect
however if you use an enzyme retrieval
which you know is some markers prefer in
this case you get a really nice really
beautiful stain
pattern and the serial section you can
see exactly where as binding but is
wrong it's not a nuclear marker is not
the right button but can be very
believable to him back to that first
quote just because it's nice and strong
does not mean that is necessarily
correct and I'd like to thank my
colleague Haley Whitaker from UCL's
allowing me to use this image and a
number of images in this presentation
and it's not just that fixation contains
a patent staining so if you take this
marker as I please Gatsby City on most
parson and it's got exactly as you would
expect for at least caspase-3 antibodies
cytoplasmic you can see the rapid Tata
bodies thinning positively everything
you would want but if you put that onto
a piece of human frozen tissue then you
get entire the wrong pattern staining
you've got a cell surface marker those
ought to be an expression an epithelial
tissue and that's not what you would
expect from Cleese caspase-3 so again
fixation can change the pattern of
staining and lastly also as I say that's
not an exclusive list is you've got to
remember the staining intensity is not a
guide to positivity so in the bottom
left hand corner of the screen you can
see and a marker connie's at each to I
expressed in the prostate gland is
expected to be a nuclear marker and but
its expression is very delicate so when
we validated as antibody on on the
bonding then we took its own particular
level we could not get it to a really
three plus intensity but we had it so we
had a really nice signal to noise it's
very minimal background but it's a
delicate thing if you take the marker
the top that is a nonspecific background
of muscle and prostate my can't show you
the post of staining which is somewhere
in there pavilion but just because it is
a darker intensity does not mean as real
and that can be highlighted even further
and by some work devastated in a paper
by Angela de marzo recently and and
where he's demonstrated on the left hand
side a
reason 1 & 6400 on some negatives and
knowing to be untranslated negative
cells on the are negative and you get
nice poster standing in the positive
transfected cells but if you take and I
lack concentration up you continue to
have some really nice poster standing on
your transfected cells but your your M
your negatives I'll start on positive so
you're getting a lot of false negatives
so you really got to know what you're
trying to achieve and then you've got to
have the right controls in place or not
be able to get this accurate
a good framework look like and so the
two papers are good to refer to mainly
see this purple through this webinar the
one the bottom left us was co-written by
myself and a number of colleagues and
across industry as well as academia and
and then one of the writers is a people
that I helped I work under and when I
was working in the farm industry so the
begin with I think nobody would disagree
that the first thing you need to
understand is a target so you need to
really understand biology of that target
you need to have a fool the studio if
you have was already occurred what has
been stained is anything in some cases
that might be stuffing stained and and
that will help you to work out the
subset of localization of that target
you know what the biological relevance
is I know then also be able to help you
to identify the cells and tissues you
might use so you'll be able to work out
what your positive and negative cell
lines are and that you'll be able to
identify your positive and negative
control tissues and that allows you to
be able to pull together all the control
material you need to be able to validate
your assing and wide I could highlight
to you is that as our line controls you
pick can be users so we get the tissue
if you treat them the right way so you
can take cells you can grow them up you
can and spin them down you can fix them
in formaldehyde as if you were facing a
small biopsy or a piece of tissue you
can process at the F and the parson and
then they are treating it sitting it as
a surrogate in that what you're trying
to determine is specificity of your
antibody and by that I mean that you're
asking the question whether the antibody
binds to a protein that has been
formally fixed and partial embed it has
gone through an icy process it's not
trying to tell you whether there's any
background now because I really can't do
that because of the amount of material
in there is only to ourselves it's just
asking the question does it by native
bee tissue it is better Pia stuff so
there are number of ways of doing that
first one and I would highlight to use
knockout
so a knockout cell line we have truly
knocked out the gene of interest in this
particular case is PDL one and there's
been a gene excision by my Talon
constructs to knock legs on off of PDL
one out then you get up your positive in
the parent and a complete negative in
the nor concern but you can also if you
haven't gone okay to hand and they're
not always easy to be able to make you
can do a knock them okay and then those
cases what you're looking at is an SI
RNA transfection
and you don't get a perfect knockdown so
some cells will take up the transfection
reagent and will knock down on others
will not do you get this get het genius
patent staining which is actually and so
is helpful because you can see the
positivity and you can see the negative
it is if I call you a nice negative
positive control but the key thing here
in each case is to confirm that so in
the last time panel with a knock out the
null guy was confirmed by deep
sequencing seguin nose to knocker a
right hand panel they use the Western
blot in order to be able to determine
there was a reduction in the amount of
signal for users h2 and so that gives
you confidence that the material you're
using will allow you to make a
definitive conclusion over your M cell
line control so sometimes again you can
knock up that I can not combine so you
can still these other methods so in this
case this is an overexpression and and
that can be using a native cell line
that has not expressed a target in this
particular example this is a PDL -
that's transfected and enter that
interactivity so I'm but then stain the
90 PDL 1 minus negative so it's a
similar process under the left hand side
and you've got video on transfected 2-3
spoon of funky PDL 1 so you can use
overexpression cell lines as well and
where you need to again sometimes that
might be difficult and you can still use
native cell line expression an example
out here from the paper in the corner
mmm g2 is negatives for added 1a and we
can confirm that by a Western blot on
the s2 cells are positive and found 1a
and you can use those by fixation FB and
then boo sensing a uses as a surrogate
for tissue simulator you need to cut the
tissue because there's only the tissue
that's going to be able to demonstrate
your sensitivity and cross reactivity so
in this case you we would use a multi
district microarray and that tissue
Micra contains all the information you
want with positive material negative
material you can do that multiple tutors
different tissue microarrays and it
gives you confidence that your arcing is
working really well and but something to
show Marquis will work so you can always
rely on exactly the same thing every
time you go and through your framework
you have to be specific to your target
to some specific target acquire specific
validation on the right hand side you
can see the tissue marker is run in this
case is completely negative but that's
because it's a very specific marker and
there's only experiment you have
functioning olfactory neurons and
therefore you have to use that single
piece of tissue in or develop antibody
all that makes sense
and the last thing to highlight is
orthogonal validation so we talked about
fog in the validation regularly with in
the validation field as using other
methodologies and try and prove or add
additional and informations try and
prove your undercoating specific now
that's great when it works on in this
case is a great man this is a great
antibody to see cr6 works and he knows
the chemistry and the Western block
which you expected or cut 42 color
Dalton's is entirely doing that on the
best employees a case and I've seen many
antibodies where the Western blot is
positive but the IAC antibody doesn't
stain and also some the other way around
I see is positive West applause negative
and you've got to know the strengths of
weaknesses of your method and you've got
to you know use those in conjunction
with each other but not simply rely on
one method to validated below because if
you take this individual clone we know
because we've tested this you can take
random order you can run an immune aside
the chemistry and on fixed cells and it
will be negative we can run on a full
cytometry and there will also be
negative we can run it and across
species I see with most of it is the
chemistry and random units against the
other wants to be negative this is a
human specific marker and we will lock
me all highlight that within the
datasheet to make sure that everybody is
aware of that so you just got to make
sure you know how your asses are acting
and you don't always pull the same route
because it might not work because of in
the next slide about one size does not
fit on and what I mean by that if you're
lovers of golf this cool and this will
help you so you you need a number of
different club
you back because in an example this is
this if you're a golfer you can look at
that parser you think that's not
particularly difficult if you don't hit
it straight
you've not got any particularly bad bits
of rough to to hold you up while you try
and get in that trouble however you
would take a different approach if you
were honest go for and you know the two
Brutus has to be different because they
are different and the different holes
okay the same applies to adequate
validation so they like to refer to
people in the bottom right hand corner
and although this particular validation
method might look really complicated
it's actually not so everything that's
on the screen now is simmered of always
have stopped the round surround and the
taking your target protein it's specific
to your target and it doesn't detect the
proteins with background for example and
this is what you want for your basic
validation package so there are a number
of golf clubs you need a nord get across
to them to the whole jig in your driver
a button and I'm positive though you
would require but when you need to go
into something there's much more
dedicated where you need to do an IV D
and V to diagnosis sources like we do or
or a companion diagnostic or a coral
antibiotics quarter for clinical trial
work which is what the purpose of this
paper was then you need to add extra
clubs to bag you need to ask some
additional assistance and some experts
in order to be able to help you do that
this is the additional level of
validation of my term enhanced
validation so for example and again this
is not exclusive for example if you are
looking at phosphorylation marker M such
as fossil round 50 here you muster in a
dephosphorylation the demonstrate that
you're looking at for severe 15 on track
15 just an absolute wreck suit Oh an
equally if you're going to be making a
clinical trial marker and that's going
to be going across a number of different
disease indications you know you need to
be able to test and knows and you know
this is the data from this particular
fossil rod 50 on gastric TNBC and CRC so
you need to tailor the information and
validation to
target you're looking for and it doesn't
stop there so you can also uh no not for
an IV D you without all of these things
and you need to know the
interoperability you need to know when I
was stable the antigen is the epitope is
and when you cast actually need to know
they the stability the antibody you need
to have portability between sites all of
these things are really important to get
right but that's for your enhance
foundation not necessarily for your your
simple basic package so whatever took
flavor would look like as I just in this
particular section of the stock it is
around making sure you got fooled that's
a literature review the M you know from
that where your subcellular
localizations are what your negative
positive cell lines or controls are
going to be in tissue and in cell lines
and using cell lines as appropriate to
do that I'm up to a point and that
you've got a good IC method available to
you and you should consider using
automation in order to be able to try
that out where you can and and you've
got good controls so by doing all of
this you will generate the good controls
that you need to be able to use in the
rest of your validation framework so
once you've done that you can start to
put antibodies through that process and
it should be relatively easy to do so
you can think as an example here which
is been counted as a PD one clone and
which is you know we've got from the
basic validation package we are some
data on the human tonsil looks very good
but we can enhance that with some cell
line data these are from pesticide
laboratories where we've got PDL one
knowing levels of and of expression for
e plus down for negative and we can
demonstrate using the same go to go on
the same instrument three plus two plus
one plus one under negative but we can
enhance that further so we can put that
on to a non small cell lung cancer TM a
160 court EMA and there from that we can
demonstrate the sensitivity of the a C
so in that panel of Thor and tissue
microwave course you have video on
staining on a tumor that's strong
in the bottom right hand corner you got
the term understanding negatively for
PDL one but has got pd-1 positivity in
the immune cell function and macrophages
so you can take all of that and then
hand square your individual data and
then you can take it to another level
which which we do an ab cam which is to
put it on to the other PMA set some of
multiple different and tumors they help
to to tease out if there's any other
areas and you know cancer is it could be
relevant we can put it on to normal
tissues we can put on the most wrap
tissues in this case we know it happens
to be negative we can put it we can test
an immune aside the chemistry which we
do and demonstrating that it works for
the Minnesota chemistry this particular
marker M and we can demonstrate it works
a Western blot I think really we know it
doesn't work for flow cytometry so you
can use that whole package of data set I
gave you confidence on what you're doing
and once you've done that you've got
your framework once you go your
framework you can bolt on the other
application that you want to run in this
case I'm showing some multiplexing data
so you can take that ground work you've
done for validating around the body you
know it's specific you know that it
works on your tissue type but what you
don't know in this particular stain of
white passing is what the session is
going to stain and so you can do that
work having confidence so that you know
well and the antibody performs and so
you can put that in multiple decisions
you can multiplex it and in a number of
variety of ways on different tissues
that you know it's expressed on and it
makes that extra extra validation work
really well within the multiplexing area
because of the foundations that you've
already built so to end off and
summarize for me the key to good
validation is good framework you've got
to have high quality literature analysis
and your you can use our line controls
and as a surrogate for tissue for you're
looking for specificity and but you need
to extend the under multiple tissues
look at my current levels as well as the
sensitivity of that in a normal tissue
expression and in multiple patients
practition you can extend the repurchase
of instability where you need to miss
your additional golf clubs you might
want to add in but that's solid
foundation and that solid framework
allows you to build confidence in your
antibody to build other other methods on
top and I just like to end with some
acknowledges by my colleagues in in
Cambridge and Nigel in China and to my
colleagues in Pleasanton and awesome
balling in the US who have provided data
into this particular data pack and also
to my former colleague dr. Haley
Whittaker snow cover layout UCL so thank
you very much
m4 for listeners webinar and I'd like to
the opportunity to pass you now on to
Damien for his presentation
Thank You dr. Howard following on from
dr. Howard excellent presentation on
setting up a good framework for
validating anybody's I'm going to take a
step backwards before that to when
you're first optimizing your anybody's
and show how to bond research platforms
can perform can support this
I'll do this by first giving an
introduction to the bond research
platforms run through the tools and
parameters to support the optimization
for both and touch on single Plex and
multiplex as well as providing a
description of the protocol parameters
that you can alter to support this
activity and then finish up with a bit
of a live demo of the software so you
can see how how to do this the the bond
rx platform is designed around three
very important pillars which is focused
around research as a whole it also can
apply to the process of validating
anybody the first
first pillar linked to the openness of
the system which allows anybody
validation to be as simple or as broad
as researchers like with a pleasure of
variables at their disposal the second
one for accelerate your test program
really talks around the speed and the
consistency of the platform that lets
you accelerate your work and finally
selected anybody allow you to further
your research into the laboratory
the purpose of this slide is to show
that bond direct is really an enabler to
or to make your technology its gentle on
chosen samples it's flexible in its
ability to find the optimal staining
performance and it's consistent and
efficiency efficient in its ability to
apply the same protocol over and over
again in the standardized manner
to establish you also need to start with
the bond directs or a bond directs in
the other things that you'll need
detection systems these could be a bond
former refined kid or your div kids you
refine read or you Reiki your AP rape
kits as well as you can use the research
detection systems which will allow you
to use essentially any technology that
you want to use to do your I've C
optimization with another chromogenic or
fluorescent you need your anybody's and
your anybody doing and your package
insert it's very important as that will
provide you with a guidance of where to
start with your antibody optimization
your retrieval solutions for using bonds
they're things like the episode
retriever one which is a low pH a
retrieval to I pH any different
environment Orioles your titration
containers and open containers are very
important this is what you'll be putting
your diluted anybody's in to perform
your optimizations and then the obvious
laboratory tool that you'll need as part
of your process like you could catch etc
the an IFC stain can be broken down into
three main parts you have your D prior
for annihilation the epitope retrieval
and you stay infections and the Bond
research software allows each of these
variables or actually parameters to be
changed to support your optimization
from your depersonalization you can
choose whether or not your deal acting
or not or baking and you can also alter
how you want to deal X your samples by
altering the the DX or the alcohol steps
for your epitope retrieval you can
choose between different solutions for
your heat-induced epitope retrieval or
your enzyme induced or you can choose
not to have it at all and it's part of
each of these steps you can choose
different times and temperatures to
support that application
and finding the standing protocol you
can design your own there are templates
this start we're there with this
standard to divide see protocols with
your own CFS example which works with
the lighter by system got a new range
you can use that as a template to create
your own staining protocol which can
also support your different dilutions
your different incubation times your
temperatures as well as even changing
different dispense profiles to support a
full application for how you want to
optimize for that particular test
this slide just shows an example of two
of those potential protocols and I'll
run through these is a bit more because
I want to do a demo at the end you can
see just in the slide yeah that there
are a number of variables which as a UV
you have complete control to edit these
parameters
and spend too much state too much time
in going into the protocol optimization
parameters but if there's a few things
that I'd like to touch on the first is
that it's really good to change one
variable at a time this will help you
attribute the performance of the obvious
thing to the change variable
the second thing we recommend is often
to do things in triplicate so again that
you can be ensure that your we've
designed a protocol or optimized anybody
that is going to be consistent with the
workflow that you have
and then finally it's important to
consider protocol compatibility with
your existing workflows you can use the
bond to design protocols to basically do
anything that you want so the way the
bomb works is it like you get optimum
time and speed from the system if you're
using like protocols with different
times so by planning around your design
of experiments to use different times
and to get sorry similar times you can
get the most out of your system with
really rapid IHC in two and a half hours
I'll touch on multiplexing briefly it
has an added complexity that needs to be
considered this is validating a single
stain
if the product and protocol are not
designed for reproducibility even the
most consistent consistent automated
stainer will have variable results key
considerations are anybody optimization
you should optimize them by themselves
and then as a panel to show them
standing is not lost or also consider
what pretreatment is best what works
well for one anybody may negatively
impact another
sequence the anybody's and tection
components should be added this can vary
between different technologies and the
different antibodies that you want to
use consider market localization and
multiplex type you expect your markers
to be cur localized do you need a
permanent stain what contrasts we need
for all feed into your decisions in
terms of how you design you your test
and finally when you need to strip or
remove previous components in the essay
or something to try them all these
things you know when you're designing a
an experiment or an optimization or
getting to a point where you want to
bail it out in anybody you really need
to consider the system as a whole which
is your your antibody your detection
system and your automated solution and
design them together to get the best
possible solution
now I'm going to run through a bit of a
demo of the software with you so you can
see how easy it is to optimize your
anybody's in practice and then
eventually move that from your
optimization into your chosen protocol
via validated products
now I'm going to give you a run-through
of the bond software and show you how
easy it is to set up optimization
protocols and schedules and then what
you can eventually use for your final
antibody and fun validator to anybody so
this is the bond research like a login
screen so the first thing you and I want
to do as part of your research is to set
up a study and this would be the thing
that you know do to set up your
different protocols and your slides so
you can do your optimization
as part of this you can name it anything
you want and aid in different study
names or different comments that help
you identify what it is that you're
trying to do part of the selection you
can also choose different DX protocols
as a preamp to save you time later on
when you're trying to set those things
up
now one of the first things you often
think of is setting up be anybody that
you want to optimize but actually you
can sort of take a step back from that
when we set up an alibi on the bottom
software what we usually do is we link
it to the protocol that you want to test
and this saves time the long run and me
and I'll show you why that is so I guess
if we go backwards first one of the
things I want to show you is that you
may not necessarily want to use the
protocols that come standard if you want
to optimize two different parameters
that you know this to anybody might
perform better on so one of the things
you may want to do is create your own
protocol the ICF protocol is often a
good place to start for standard baby HD
tests just because this is what's used
for the Novik astra HD anybody and has
been designed to be a very consistent
product really - enough air turnaround
time on the bond but if we use this in
the template one of the first things you
want to do if you want to change it is
your first copy this and then you define
a name that did unique to you so for
instance in my fetus eyes - yes with he
did anybody
to find an abbreviated name and then
from II can then go through and tailor
the protocol such as it fit so if this
is a very standard sort of protocol that
you'll often see with the peroxide block
you Palmer and you dare beat the market
here is your primary anybody and they
didn't if you can change your time so if
you want to experience you know that we
want to get to a longer incubation time
you can change it
and you can also change your temperature
so one of the things you do is you can
take it from the standard ambient
temperature and then you can choose a
temperature that makes sense to you so
this could be 42 degrees in the face
you also have the ability to include
extra washers if that's what you want to
do and yeah this is the bomb I'll show
they are water here beacon 9 we alter
the washers in between or you can also
add extra washes if that's what you want
to do through the things that wash step
here
once you've designed a protocol we were
happy with hit save and this will be
automatically sharp in your protocol
so you can also do this we're not just
your standing protocols but you can also
do this with your freestanding protocols
like your Heat retriever protocols
again if you want to edit these we can
change your names
that's copy we can change the name here
say for one change in temperature
and again we can click onto this and
change
from honors goes down to nine seven and
I can also put on two for one - do you
really have a lot of flexibility in
terms of how you wanted to dominate
things inside
so now I have my heap retrieving
protocol and my standing protocol I
didn't want to think about what my
anybody is I want to test if I move to
the reagent setup screen I have a number
of options that I can do here
if
of city trees for example I may want to
set that up as a city 3 150 as a
starting point for my optimization and
they will do a 1 in 50 or 100 in a 1 in
200 when you think of optimizing a large
number of anybody's and validating a lot
of time through anybody if you're doing
this for a hundred different anybody
with 3 different optimizations
that's 300 different and ability you
want to create what we find is a lot of
people like to simplify this for
themselves and and set up templates for
their optimization and I might call
something as simple as anybody one look
or from the popular one is T one and
keep it nice and simple
you can choose your anybody but you can
also do things like approach as well and
then from here you can set your default
staining protocol social instant is the
protocol that I set up earlier and this
means this just saves time later on when
I'm setting up a slide and that this
will automatically be programmed in I
can still change these parameters and
I'm turning up the slide but by having
it here already
it saves quite a bit of time and we'll
set up why keep retrieval one and you
can choose to eat retrieval and then xym
or one or either or both and then we can
say that and then we can do the same
again the next one and this one and I
ended up using for my autocorrelation
yeah but my anybody answer my protocols
can then move back to my slide setup
screen I have my case here and then I
can add a slide
and in here I can select my first
anybody now let's say I was doing a 33
at 150 I can then add this up here in
the slide comment section and when I
print my label this will this will shop
on my label and so I can identify what
my reagent is in that way and that means
I can use my p1 for lots of different
experiments through our time and I just
alter my comment here so as mentioned
previously I probably want to do three
of these just to be consistent and then
the sales and they want to do my t2
which allow me to do my my one in 100
and again I set up three agrees and add
three cloves and you can see on the
right hand side here my six I'd be now
set up
so once I've got my slides I then want
to set up on the instrument so I'll go
through a few steps the first thing is
I'll print my label
and I'll put these on my slides and get
a trip for my instrument the second
thing I want to do is set up my antibody
so that the instrument can recognize it
so I will show the area they were
different you can use bond titration
containers or bond open containers do
you grab one of those and that is what
you put your diluted anybody into so I
have a container here in front of me I
have my scanner next to me what I'll do
is I'll scan the barcode is on the
container and it should pop up is one
like so I then select the anybody that I
want to designate this container to
see one
what number so I have the ability to
container and then I can choose an
expiry date and make sense
first okay I can do that for as many
anybody's as I want and that will be
registered
now I have my anybody container
registered I have my slides the next
thing I want to do is set up on the
issue so what I'll do now is I'll load
the container onto the instrument which
in this instance is the bond rx which
you can see here and we've already
preloaded refine kit and I'll load my
slides up I'll do that now quickly
okay so let it be the anybody onto the
instrument as well as the few slides and
like us loads up now will then be able
to once we float it up we can then press
play and start the run and that
essentially is the completion of our
first anybody optimization experiment
and once you've done this once setting
them up each time gets quicker and
quicker and easier and easier because
you have your predefined anybody's and
protocol already prepped there you don't
have to kind of go through to be set up
ever
each time so your protocol is already
there you're anybody templates are
already there so each time you want to
surf in your case it's just as simple as
clicking or anybody working you're
creating your slides doing your dilution
which is probably the biggest part and
then pressing play
please normally we'll preload but one of
these and had inflicted but it's quite
easy to fix and selecting trauma one and
that's loaded there
in the first anybody this is the example
with the three slides and once that is
ready you then press play and the
instrument will schedule and that will
run and it is simple as that
and that concludes the demo that is
going to show you today and I think what
we can do now is open up for questions
thank you
you
thank you gentlemen for your informative
presentations we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we will answer as many of your questions
as we have time for now those questions
we are in unable to answer live today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be answered via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration
okay dr. house let's start with you
let's go with this question for labs
that are entrenched with their existing
antibodies what suggestions do you have
for lab staff to encourage their labs to
validate new antibodies regular question
at Christy I think that's a really
important point and if this is a
clinical assay then obviously the
patient has to come first so the
question you have enough to ask is what
additional data to this particular
antibody to fight now if it's more
sensitive if it can be demonstrated to
be more sensitive or the lot of our
variability is is minimal from this
particular supplier
and then you're gaining a patient
benefit and by doing that I think it's
clear that you would want to do that
within your your clinical workflow and
so you've got to be able to little at
work in order to make your antibody
working in your hands so you need to
have a really good PIM idea why you want
to change that but if one change either
gives you less background staining or a
higher sensitivity without a lower
concentration of antibodies those are
the reasons for why you would want to to
move on to a two validated new marker
thank you doctor how it now Damien let's
go over to you for this question now
it's two parts how do I keep track of
all the changes and variations that I
make from protocol to protocol when
doing optimizations and do I need to
write them down separately or does the
instrument record all of these for me
Thank You Christy the instrument can
record all of this so it's really up to
your lab processes in terms of how you
want to write it down or if you need to
at all but after you've done a run or
set up your anybodies or your cases you
can then go into the software and you
can pull out the information for not
only each run through your slide history
so you can see the run as it went on the
instrument on the time and that will
give you your anybody details your kids
details your lot numbers and all the
information that you should have first
pre-programmed into it as well as you
can then go into your protocol screen
and you can get a protocol report so the
protocols that we designed earlier you
can export a PDF protocol report and
what that will give you is every step of
the protocol from the reagents for
different times and temperatures until
you have a record of that to
cross-reference so you'll have all the
information in some easy bit export PDFs
that you can put with your page records
Thank You Damian and now dr. Howard
let's go over to you
and this question has a few parts so mm
I'll start here sometimes an antibody
target isn't one size fits all for
example CB 11 breast and gastric Alka
lemon heme and could be better supported
by an antibody for each indication first
is one that covers all multiple same
target antibodies retrievals etc create
a burden on a lab and create a risk of
mix-ups versus a single solution do you
think labs should tailor their
antibodies to the test or prioritize
workflow and risk reduction
legatus yeah I think that's a great
question and I'm quite a difficult one
however I think my personal view is that
and again it comes back to what is the
patient get out of this so if the best
way to treat that patient is to have and
multiple target antibodies and to be
able to pull those those different
medications out from each other then
that's the way it should be and the lab
is able to use other means such as some
great em lending systems are available
and from formica and others in order to
be able to minimize the risk of mix-ups
and by printing labels directly onto
onto the slide then that should help to
solve that however they got the balance
that out and were the single so if the
single solution is is feasible and it is
not and deliver any difficulty to that
patient and if it possible it also clear
those additional patient benefit then
then there would be no reason to to
change to minimize that risk and that's
what I would recommend so it's kind of
down to water being very patient centric
now our next question doctor how would I
believe this one's for you and it's two
parts do you recommend on slide controls
and do you prefer known tissue positives
or cell lines and why
so thank you for that I am I if you look
at a slide 20 where I am now then I
would recommend on slide controls where
where you can do and sometimes as that's
difficult to do because it's something
that will depend on the size of the
piece of tissue that you are putting on
your block and you have to fit all of
these things onto your on do you slide
the same time however I would recommend
them and I think if you can use a
mentorship positive that's great
and or a smile line that equal gate I
think the key thing is what those cell
lines are tissue controls are
demonstrating which is that you're not
just got a single level of expression so
you're not just looking up three plus
positive when the test tissue that you
got on the same slide maybe a one plus
positive because that ants like control
is then not and referencing in the right
way so a change in the character of
slide doesn't run particularly well etc
you might not static that difference of
three plus positive but your your test
issue chemical negative for that reason
you need to have on your on your and
tissue positive a mix where possible of
positivity so 3 plus 10 1 plus or in
this particular case cell lines and a
reference here this decides our lines
here you've got anywhere from a three
plus two plus into one plus and a
negative by having those in there you
can see our negatives that could become
background be so or you can see a one
plus will become a negatives and in
those cases you can flag very easily
whether and you have an issue with your
standing run or that individuals light
at the time so you know I don't think it
matters overall but as long as you're
gonna make sustaining that you can help
to give you confidence over your over
your run in the time
Thank You dr. Howard and you don't what
have you answer this next question well
what are the best trips and tools for
files on valve staining Oh another one
thank you very much I think and what's
really important my son - hey which is
something that happens in the resource
market frequently is to try and design
your methodology by using some of the
available kits on the market but what I
would recommend strongly is you tailor
your your secondary agents around the
ISO type of primary so you can use a
blocking reagent or to build to block
most of the IgG and within the most
tissue and the initial m3 primary
antibody step put your program antibody
on if you had the prime antibody happens
to be an IgG one you can use an anti
adg-1 Manti body and that is whatever
species you wish to link into your
polymer get a rabbit or a goat or
whatever happens to be and I'm by doing
that you're minimizing the amount of
most of most reaction that you will find
and I find that that protocol which
we've we have and on the like a bond
works really well
now it looks like we have time for one
more question doctor how it let's end
this QA with you
how does KO validation in Western blot
and ICC relate to performing IHC
successfully so thank you I think that
the Anoka validation is a really good
way of validating right so you it's
something that we do a lot on napkin and
and you can see the examples of and this
slide so I refer to this real easy to
talk but you where you're not go Val ax
dating you can use Western blot very
clearly and easily and quickly to be
able to show and that you've knocked out
a kind of interest and and you need to
do that in order to confirm when you're
using an ax cell line palette truly you
have knocked it out or knock the donors
as of the case on the right hand panel
so we do relate really very well but
ultimately if you want to demonstrate
administer chemistry you will other take
those now going to cell lines and you
will have to palate them building
through the FFPE
and put them on our tissue slide and
understand them and that will give you
the absolute confidence that you've got
that NACO but there should be no reason
why it wouldn't work
thank you again to dr. will Hallett and
Damien Caulfield for their time today
and their important research we would
also like to thank laborat and our
sponsor leica Biosystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us and for their
interesting questions again just a
reminder those questions we did not have
time for today and those that will come
in during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand and labradorite you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's by the event thanks for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon